hi everyone I hope you're all staying
healthy at home I know it is a very
tough time right now all of us are
recommended to stay at home and at the
same time we should be keeping ourselves
active so today I'm going to share with
you a 15 minute low-impact
heat workout which you can do from the
comfort of your own home in a very small
space so no equipment needed no noise no
sound and no impact all right so it's
going to be seven exercises okay and we
want to repeat the circuit twice let's
get started so each workout will be for
45 seconds lungs with 15 seconds break
in between okay and the first three
exercises it will be working mainly on
young legs so let's take it nice and
easy let's then sugar with a pot with
your toes pointed forward let's just
warm your legs up a little bit okay so
the first workout is going to be a squat
to a lunge right so stand sugar with the
pads toes pointed forward as you squat
bring your hands forward alright good so
squat and then take one step back and
lunch good squat nice and easy
alternating between your legs good we're
just warming up your legs for the first
workout keep going each time you take a
lunge try to go deeper so try to get
your knees close to the floor very good
so chest up back straight good there you
go almost there you should feel your
body being warmed up your hip flexes
opening up as well that's one more left
lunge squat right side give me one more
on each side and very good shake it out
okay the next workout what I'm going to
do is stand at the forward of your neck
mat as you take a lunch bag reverse
lunge
as you come up twist
and we want to work on your obliques
okay so step back twist knee to elbow
step back knee to elbow so just working
on one leg for the first round step back
and twist good there you go
twist and reach if you can't get your
knee as high up that's okay just go as
high as you can if you want to challenge
yourself then tap good you should really
feel the work on your right leg
feel the burn on your glutes feel the
burn on your thighs good again it is
also challenging your balance so Luke's
spread ahead find one focal point keep
going
last few more and rest it out all right
now let's stand facing forward cut the
lunge with a side kick okay so stand
forward again with your left leg step
back into a curtsy lunge licks across
and as you come up tap and raise it to
the side alright still working on your
right side up and back good so it's a
little kick to the side to work on your
outer glutes if this is too challenging
curtsy tap up tap and curtsy good race
it up tap and down if not straight up
and straight back remember you want your
body to be facing forward
nice tap it up and back good nice and
gentle no noise there you go
low-impact but you should feel the burn
on your legs
very good okay now let's work a little
bit on our upper body alright so let's
get down onto the mat the next workout
is a push-up with a heel tap so get into
a nice push-up position one push up tap
opposite side tap and back down one push
up pike your butt up
tap and tap good if this is too tough
reach towards your knee okay or if you
need to drop onto your knees
tap and tap remember the goal is to Pike
your butt up working on the flexibility
of your hamstrings as well reach tap and
tap good let's go keep going give me one
last push up down push it up tap and tap
and rest it up okay
next lateral shoot through this is going
to challenge a little bit of your
coordination as well as to work on your
car alright so starting in a high plank
I want to release one out and just shoot
through and release and just kick
through all right good kick it to the
side kick it to the side so bring your
arm close to your chest very good kick
and kick nice and easy
opposite side through the work on your
car maintaining that plank position good
flat back nice kick it whoa keep going
push it you are all of that huh nice
work guys keep going we're almost
halfway through how will work out few
more find your balance and rest it out
alright the second final workout is a
low-impact Burpee again working on our
total body okay so start in a high plank
position
what I waiting to do is take two steps
forward come up and reach and stretch
back left leg back right knee back again
and stretch good down really bring both
feet as far forward as you can good back
and back keep going let's not slow the
pace down
let's bring the pace out forward and up
down back forward and up good feel your
heart rate pumping nice keep pushing it
up down a few more and rest it ah okay
we can't end the workout without doing a
plank and the final challenge is a in
out price
alright so watch me first okay again
start in a high plank position what I
need to do is take a left right leg out
of the mat bring it in and out okay just
in and out good
there you go making sure that you
maintain the high plank positions
throughout and do not sway your hips too
much okay
don't do this this is strong keeping a
steady position in and out and just
focus focus on ending the first set very
good in and out in and out push through
strong body strong core this is it
holder body workout last few more stay
strong and you will get a one-minute
break all right very very good job take
a shot
one-minute break and we want to repeat
the entire circuit once more alright so
if it was a stretch it out a little bit
push back get into a downward dog and
just breathe
we're not rushing to go anywhere right
now okay
just breathe in and breathe out and then
slowly get into a high plank lower
yourself down into a Cobra push-up know
you showed us a little bit very good
and now push yourself back into a
child's pose and just breathe
feel the stretch on your back feel the
stretch along your arms as well as your
glutes and sighs okay all right are we
ready
this is your second round okay you know
all the workouts I want you to give me
your best effort
so the first worker is a squat to a
lunch and this time I want you to stay
low so squat lunge stay low and lunch
this is going to up the challenge good
squat and lunge good stay low view the
burn on your thighs your glutes hah nice
slow and easy
you can have a low-impact workout but
it's going to be equally as intense view
the burner nice squat low do not come up
you have 10 seconds left
down and push it back good
oh my thighs are screaming good keep
going low one last one low and up
alright guys we have two legs correct we
worked on our right side just now this
time we want to work on our left legs so
take a right step back okay ready
reverse lunge up and twist good and
twist working on your obliques working
on your legs and working on your core
and balance up and twist good as high up
as you can nice
remember do not hunch forward feel the
burn on your left glutes and thighs good
keep going oh
breathe and just pace your breathing
okay last few more give me two more
that's one more and shake it off all
right curtsy lunge with a slight kick
again this time we want to work on our
left side so bring your right leg back
okay so stand shooter with the pad
remember cross them like right leg over
your lap so cut see to the side and tap
bring it up squeeze the outer part of
your right glutes and back up nice four
more challenge find your balance
squeeze good curtsy and squeeze nice
there you go ah I can hear like musics
playing in the background right now and
my thighs are on fire very good let me
know in the comments below if you are
sweaty
if you're feeling of the burn let me
know okay and we want to keep staying
active from the comfort of our own homes
very good okay let's get down onto the
back push-up with an ankle tap or a knee
tap okay choose your option right high
plank ready let's go one push up tap
opposite cross the opposite side push
your butt up cross over nice cross take
it up and back down tap whoa very good
working on your shoulders your chest
muscles with every push up remember to
go low you are strong you are halfway
there okay give me as many pushups as
you can
keep going up and breathe breathe in if
you go down without as you come up and
tap and tap one last push up and up good
let's roll shoot through okay oh I'm
drenched in sweat already
okay let's get into all fours let's get
up hover and ready let's cross over kick
to the side and kick it out very good
cake and cake good remember to bring
your arm close to your body all right
nice keeping your body tight and close
together kick it kick keep going oh if
you can't find yourself coordinating in
this pose well keep trying okay one step
at a time one movement at a time release
the left take the right release the
right kick the left that's it few more
that's one more and oh all right oh
episode a little bit low impact burpees
because it's low impact we want to go as
fast as we can all right let's go high
play ready bring both legs in up down
out in and up okay as many as you can in
45 seconds this is your challenge to
yourself and your body up reach back and
tap reach back down up and push it back
up alright in squeeze your abs as you
come up okay maintain a high position
keep going last few more koop breathe
out it in up that's one more up let's go
up and stand tall okay one final workout
we have to workout with we have to end
the workout with a plank alright let's
get down high plank spread your fingers
for a firmer base okay out out in in
good out out in in there you go making
sure that you're not hiking or arching
your back okay do not hike or do not dip
it this is wrong
keeping a firm foundation flat back keep
going
one final workout and you are done
yes you heard me right one final 20
seconds
keep pushing out out in in
Oh totally drenched totally ready to
start my day totally ready to have an
amazing day even at home let's go last
few more last one more ah
alright guys that was a 50 minute
workout if you enjoy the workout if you
are sweating like me be sure to leave
your comments below give this video a
thumbs up share it on and do check out
my youtube channel as I have a lot more
different home workouts from beginner
levels to advanced level I know that
this is a tough time but it is very
important for us to stay home stay safe
and stay active for your own health and
also for those around you so remember to
also subscribe to my youtube channel and
I'll see you in my next workout all the
best